allies that his regime's
capability to deliver nuclear
weapons in different ways. Is
growing. New information tonight
on the north Korean strongman's
brutality and his unrelenting
ambition to threaten his enemies
. With these photos showing
tracks just under the surface,
Kim Jong un's regime claims to
have tested an underwater drone
capable of carrying a nuclear
warhead. Kim himself was
photographed beaming next to a
drone. North Korean state media
says the mission of this weapon
is to quote make a super scale
radioactive tsunami to destroy
enemy warships and ports. It
claims this drone traveled
underwater for nearly 60 hours,
then detonated warhead and blew
up a mock enemy ports. Some
analysts are skeptical of the
real capability of this weapon.
There's a lot we don't
understand about how they're
controlling this weapon, whether
it's pre programmed or whether
they're actively maneuvering
this thing underwater and panda
says this drone would likely be
vulnerable to being destroyed by
the U. S and south Korean navies
before it flushes out to sea.
But he says it could still be a
threat. There is nothing
preventing North Korea from in
principle, putting a nuclear
device on an underwater vehicle
like this and detonating it,
they could use it against massed
formations of surface warships
in testing. An underwater drone
takes a page from Vladimir
Putin's playbook. Russia claims
to have developed a submarine
launched nuclear power
underwater vehicle designed to
strike enemy cities with nuclear
weapons, but the Kremlin's
offered no real proof of it. In
recent days, Kim has apparently
have been successful in testing
another menacing weapon. From
mobile launchers. North Korea
fired off long range nuclear
capable cruise missiles. Eye
catching video shows the
missiles hugging coastlines and
mountains. Aircraft fly fairly
low, and if they will be nuclear
armed, that's going to present.
I think a substantial challenge
for missile defense in the
morning in northeast Asia. This
comes as a new report from human
rights watchdog group Korea.
Future details barbarous
conditions inside Kim's network
of prisons. What it says was a
pattern of summary executions,
torture, rape and starvation. At
least one prisoner, it said, was
forced to eat cockroaches and
rodents to survive a woman
jailed for crossing the border
into China, the report says, was
forced to have an abortion when
she was seven or eight months
pregnant. Any drop of foreign
blood dropped into North Korea
is an offense to the Kim regime
. And thus these poor ladies had
relationships with Chinese men
and will forcibly. He returned.
Are subjected to this criminal
treatment. North Korea's mission
to the U. N has not responded to
CNN's request for comment on the
new report. But Kim's regime